this is some [__] that all of you are
struggling with with somebody that's
been in the trenches of working in
businesses since I was 14. this right
here is a [__] struggle people
struggle with forgiveness at their own
expense I have way too many friends
relatives close business acquaintances
that are terrible at this like one
strike policies and they [__] carve
out people because of their own
insecurities and weaknesses their own
fears their own hurt their own softness
they don't have the capacity to forgive
meanwhile the capacity for forgiving is
one of the most important traits finding
your own happiness
hurting the other person you're hurting
yourself please this video can be a
monster for so many it could be a
[__] monster for so many please
understand this a colleague a relative a
[__] friend get your [__]
forgiveness up
and watch you smile a lot more